hey guys welcome back to the game spot
stage here at e3 2016 i am your host
mary and i am joined by my lovely
co-host peter brown again hello it's so
good to see you and we also have masa
and show from bandai namco we're gonna
be talking about a dragon ball xenoverse
to today awesome so the first thing we
should probably talk about is the world
you guys released a press release that
stated that the world is seven times
bigger than the first game can you talk
a little bit about how that's going to
impact the game tomorrow once a good am
I talking to you too cool to gravity
ma-kun todo banana by John obscenity
ruin him oppressive ed seem excessive
see torito's go most rigorous any game 0
2 luego no katachi day Emma me como
Trask Aikido to kuro on acetyl chemos
Sonoma densa como Emma habito see no
quiero dos tema y baton cuando uno seis
de tratar con crema a pissy machi Emma
ok nomas toast a toast Oh este es que
dios te no mucho más de azevedo estaba
ano de hasta que esta como somos como
mochiko neo te quiero koto desu toca
Emma again secona gotta say Contino moco
not a nice case 800 cara a psyche and
aquario intuitive O'Day yellow Valley
mistletoe geo multi messy Emma on a
concrete oh so piscina que esto que
invento como fue met Emma lasagna chance
to vomit hasta que te quiero muchas so
actually discontent series working as a
hob and in the previous title we
actually had talked turkey city which
was more of a village sized uh hub and
then now now contents it is actually
working as a city and then now we're
able to actually implement more new
features thanks to the size of this up
you'll be able to do more quests maybe a
number of missions and a lot of new of
fun gameplay features that you'll be
able to experience with your friends
online so this size is definitely going
over to our victim yeah I heard at 300
simultaneous players it's able to
support is that true mikuni Jono
programmable genie a dog Cisco no do any
key dansgame home to the scope I know
he'll chase a ghost ever wants a shiver
at the community the more you set online
Nevada samba conectado con una vez SI
femina de memoria garrido toca military
toma a su amor ahora no exact name open
in America you know alright so the
actual number of players that you'll
actually be able to see on your screen
may not be exactly 300 but yes when
you're talking about the number of
players that can access yes we're
looking at three hundred and thanks
things to these numbers you'll be able
to more co-op more interact more and do
a lot of more fun things with players
online so we hope you look forward to
that that's awesome and now in the start
of the game heard that you won't be able
to fly immediately now you will be able
to in the matches because that's such a
core element of that competition itself
but sounds like you actually get
hoverboards at the beginning is that
also accurate no nimbus clouds oh it is
named Fito Boozer am I gotta give you
another Dino Keaton skill motor present
undercut about such radicchio Hannah
right they already know Joe kilometers
to the greenery give you the
demonstration of Obama Baba notary
Monahan matter tomasz gielo more correct
Emma come on I can i bestow a tota taiba
sequinned 09 discuss me know salukis a
very good question i mean i just get
home listen I know sighs no hemos hecho
look easy striking her son she must
occur no photo no bikini a no motive
itadakimasu Sanjay no mama trio john
donahoe re mismo equipo chanto Assange
amarte es on sighs techno in a garage or
Sheamus on yamato in a very cogent panic
was not ready to move on with the child
a keen on p.m. assume any animal smooth
slow its meticulous oh you very much
chief and oh you want amor SI para la
sua sumatera not in that machine mano y
mano y hasta como yo ho monte talk about
human alright so in terms of nimbus
clouds or maybe different vehicles
there's not much we can say right now we
hope you look for forward to all further
information but in terms of being able
to fly or not we're not just on on we're
not just preventing players from flying
just because we want we don't want them
to we just wanted them to search through
and look through the city in order and
play through and then finally be able to
fly and go to places that you're only
able to go to because you can fly so you
small players to go in order maybe just
like restricting them the beginning but
then they can achieve to get to new
areas that sounds cool thing doubt I've
also heard that there is a training
school that's been announced does that
mean or allude in any way that they'll
be a training mode it's a mom my jigar
it's a nice thing about NATO patola you
say gotta kill you nicky tennis game or
put it there not today about training
more directly you could oh you are
unleash my state in this organ mom mom I
must be high yes there is okay I think I
next day I was also he taking when I
they don't they're honest I don't want
any more training moving hug it out this
que no son no mark again atoka no muy
chido can I target I to a collective
state utah bhaji masala i'm a 31 kumite
I know scary ears and touch the tie was
eaten human rights oh yes in terms of
the training more mode yes we don't have
a trainer mode and just basically thanks
to the feedback from fans and not only
in terms of the training but we're
really trying trying to listen to the
comments and feedback from fans so yes
that's fantastic me it seems like you
guys have been working in tandem with
with your fans throughout the iteration
of the first game making adaptations for
the second game another thing a lot of
people wanted was local multiplayer
split screen have you guys announced
anything regarding that it'll might use
on a few double katana scream aah todo
mundo scream up on us just uh manoa
anymore peppery yes a no frying you know
you're coming boo that's it hey go who
she did I use among fio katanas get
almost a mile concert domenica tossed
aside attacking my face in solitary slow
at orientation it overnight listen 80 1
inch divert from okay cool and although
chimo don't know he can walk the two
guys named oh no I'm doing cuts no whois
national gay bar Kampai marvin silva yah
i'll jump at sydney it's not amend a
technic avicii tandis que lo mo a
certain Hawaii too so he poked th 0
comprar la Petite ocean concessions okay
let's check on at amante no puedo Samos
mo oh ok nos 1000 quiere te amo
demasiado como uno de ed de engineer
mocha macchiato ha an odm 0 0 so no
brandon hardesty no more mysterious TOC
tonight quinoa during Joshua no
fortunately I think I said she unwrapped
and a compile a stick that you anymore
alright we actually received a lot of
feedback from fans oh yes they were
there were fans saying that they want
split screen but there were also fans
who were saying that the way we did
local versus mode was good as is because
you're able to look at the stage more
freely it's more larger if you split the
screen there's just small portions that
you can see it's such a wide open field
it's actually quite hard to see but in
the first game you only had to think one
map local multiplayer exactly so there
we we are increasing increasing more
stages ok guys what's playing more are
multi a number of stages ok any idea of
how many maps so far or email you could
Scott the halothane I guess got you a
tour ma noi still see an idea I got me
higher res a quick of essence on
sunscreen optimal Tyson you'll need my
food i knows no ma mi game accountable
if you know much big screen outside be
right of me matanuska mist scummy oz
snow still due to walmart movie then
William Terry glory tonight super mario
de ma I don't eat a cookie too funny
alright so sorry we can't go into the
actual numbers but we're actually really
recreating the stages so that it fits
are the local 1 vs. 1 mode so yeah I'm
sure that'll be something satisfying ok
there's obviously the new Dragon Ball
anime series is out there dark mozzie
super habits that influence some of the
content in this game if at all though my
little humble too super I'm on good
night yo ho so sorry Taylor kimonos como
se llama also gonna do nirona it go up
at I dated this river dunno nao Sakuma
didn't say a lot of things then use of
Heidi really Heidi a bourbon sugar no ma
I come on game ouma kurosu ouma
committed a gustado she met a girl a
chicken tactical aku no ma Sid Baton oh
ah ama oh so sorry no da tomo tomosaki
antonio no ma moto moto colegio de
montejo so trois alpha chi not achieve
an emotional day anoche en agosto po
antonio no trace a halt at school knew
nemo seguro que te amo de ahi mas uno de
mizuki hana tomo motel no de mano donde
NOS toca una no kotoba murabba
Karunanidhi's kodomo on oh my god listen
Santos highly came on off you know
pursuit to be completely honest on the
broadcasting of dragon ball super
actually began after we already created
the whole concept of the game so um
we're not actually sure about how many
or maybe the content of dragon ball
super we will be able to include in the
game but we are really hoping that we
can do something and related to Dragon
Ball super so we so we hope that you
guys can look forward to further
information on that as well just one
more question if that's cool yeah like
does the Denton team have a strong
history and affinity for this series and
if you do personally how does it feel to
work with such an icon like a cultural
icon of Japan it don't aneema Dragonborn
on Lake City nobody manag I don't wanna
scream oh so na ma i'm only hope that
you'll still hate my peanut on board it
has everything to make you much either
Scotty Oh mahjong I look so good in
general fantasy Fukuda [ __ ] in a
wonderful mood anymore so como taco
their personal singing no Massa kini
sohni Venus neckla parada Chloe subpoena
marimo da da da minha though is not
poison atocha podium Satoshi to catch a
fire once I steer de la que a chant om
karate kata to enhanced a dance video to
you ma under oh and Kent can you do sort
of imagine what I did phenomenal DSP
media asking como pasa nunataq equipo de
ma us tomorrow muga as I've said right
so first of all I he uh he dongsaeng
himself is a fan so he's really happy to
be able to be involved in the
development of dragon ball game but at
the same time he feels a really strong
responsibility to work up to the White
expect a shins and hopes from fans
because we know that there are so many
fans of Dragon Balls throughout the
world so now that he has the privilege
to create a game he would really like to
work up to those expectations lots of
responsibilities as a responsibility and
real quick is there a lot of people love
the transformations that happen between
the characters but I think there were
only a few races that had
transformations are there going to be
more transformations in as University
Adama mean I operations into yo soy de
todo mundo
kodomo yamazaki tiwa mi Chiba no shizuku
scarce and hence inter nagatomo son
conocidos cuneo eat em oh my hands into
your second kinetic theory the sugar so
cuckoo good question again again a good
question yeah hi Anna lives near gmod
naka de noelia jenna is she imagenes que
como su cuarto con oh you guys are no
omoide genome or sheesh to start a mushy
anna boch touching Monica state Ananda
vana cerca de tomate Don Alberto mot
minh all day quantcast eva oh no
communal johanna Christ oh she's not
here alright so unfortunately there is
not much information that we can give
out right now but we do understand the
hopes from fans and we really understand
and we would like to you know really
accomplish this so please just look
forward to further information we
absolutely are looking forward to it and
we're looking forward to more
information about dragon ball xenoverse
to now that is slated for winter of 2016
correct correct all right muslin show
thank you so much for your time and
thank you guys for watching that was
Dragon Balls universe to there's me a
lot more so if you want to hear all the
latest on that game be sure to stay
tuned to gamespot and stick around
because we still have more coming up on
our live show at e3 2016 you're watching
the game spot stage brought to you by
airheads